[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on s'en souviendra du confinement jamais
dans son histoire la france n'apparaît
il a cumulé une telle somme de dettes
privées et publiques
les chômeurs sont des allemands très
nombreux 4 millions de gens n'ont aucun
emploi le chômage pourrait monter de 7%
environ jusqu'à 11% à la fin de l'année
prochaine d'après l'insee car la france
enregistré vous l'imaginez bien une
chute historique de son produit
intérieur brut depuis le confinement et
la consommation n'a pas repris depuis
les français n'ont pas l'air de vouloir
dépenser les 75 milliards qu'ils
auraient économisé pendant les deux mois
où ils sont restés chez eux
on s'attend donc à une explosion des
faillites d'entreprises cet automne
alors comment la france peut-elle s'en
sortir sur le plan économique pour en
débattre nous avons invité jean marc
daniel qui était que de myst professeur
à l'école supérieure de commerce de
paris et directeur de la revue sociétal
votre dernier livre c'était sur emmanuel
macron la valse folle folle de jupiter à
l'archipel
vous lui conseilleriez quoi emmanuel
macron pour sortir le pays de la crise
du club il sur le point que de
bouleversements économiques en deux mots
la crise est une crise qui n'est pas une
crise économique en tant que tel au
départ c'est un choc exogène qui a été
porté sur l'économie on a empêché les
gens de travailler pendant 55 jours
c'est ça qu'il faut réparer donc il faut
réparer les entreprises et pour réparer
les entreprises je lui conseillerais non
pas de faire 100 milliards de plans de
relance mais a baissé de 70 milliards
les impôts qu'ils doivent les
entreprises indépendamment de toute
activité ce qu'on va paître les impôts
de production et puisqu'on n'a pas
travaillé pendant 55 jours je lui
conseillerais de supprimer un certain
nombre de jours fériés pour que l'on
puisse se remettre au travail
je lui conseillerais pour conclure
d'appliquer le mot d'ordre de maurice
thorez en 1944 produire d'abord
revendiqué ensuite dominique méda vous
êtes sociologue du travail
professeur à l'université paris dauphine
votre dernier ouvrage une autre voie est
possible avec eric heyer et pascal look
iec ressort en poche chez flammarion
dans une édition augmentée il ya même un
chapitre sur la crise du coc vide et ses
conséquences ainsi qu'une préface
inédite vous lui conseilleriez quoi
emmanuel macron vous d'une certaine
manière je suis allé sous forme de
question suggérer quelque chose quand il
y avait eu le grand débat avec les
intellectuels un bien grand mot mais bon
ça s'appelait comme ça et donc je lui
avais demandé s'il pensait que c'était
une bonne idée d'investir pendant dix
ans 20 milliards d'investissements
publics supplémentaires dans la
transition écologique et il m'avait
répondu que c'était une mauvaise idée
que sarkozy l'avait fait et que ça
n'avait pas fait baisser le chômage
donc c'était pas danser dans ses
intentions il paraît que c'est ya 20
milliards prévus dans le plan de 100
milliards de relance a mais on y
reviendra il paraît ce qui n'est pas
encore sorti christian saint-etienne
professeur titulaire de la chaire
d'économie au cnam vous publié chez
odile jacob le libéralisme stratège
contre le chaos du monde
alors comment le libéralisme stratège
pourrait remédier à la crise née du coup
vite 19 alors la prise du coc vite 19 en
fait tu accélères une transformation qui
était à l'oeuvre depuis une quinzaine
d'années avec la mutation numérique sur
la base du la transformation du système
informatique
la france a pris beaucoup de retard son
système productif a pris beaucoup de
retard dans la dans la transformation
qui donc est à l'oeuvre au plan mondial
depuis une quinzaine d'années et qui se
traduit d'ailleurs aux états unis par
les gars femmes en chine par les béate
et thx et en europe à rien donc c'est
pas seulement un problème français c'est
aussi un problème européen mais en plus
nous avons un système industriel qui est
très affaibli
donc dans ce contexte moi je lui
suggérerais alors jean marc daniel a
parlé de 70 milliards moi aussi ma
recette est de 70 milliards mais pas le
la même utilisation je proposerai de
faire un fonds d'investissement avec les
banques et les fonds d'investissement de
70 milliards d'euros pourquoi 70
milliards parce que c'est la proportion
du relative de la france par rapport au
pic de l'allemagne nous sommes tombés
malheureusement à 70% du pipe de
l'allemagne nous avons régressé d'une
dizaine de points dans les dents les dix
dernières années donc on voit que ce
n'est pas seulement le coc vide le
problème et c'est 70 milliards 30
milliards venant des compagnies
d'assurance une vingtaine de milliards
venant des fonds d'investissement et
l'état mettant une vingtaine de
milliards
sergey requis 100 entreprises pour leur
permettre de se transformer nicolas
dufresne et économiste également on le
reconnaît à sa chemise rayée puisque
tous les économistes ce soir août une
chemise rayée haut fonctionnaire
directeur de l'institut rousseau vous
est le coauteur avec alain grandjean du
livre une monnaie écologique est paru en
février dernier chez odile jacob avec
une préface de nicolas hulot
alors vous lui conseilleriez quoi au
président de la république
alors je lui conseillerais premièrement
d'accentuer le plan de relance de faire
beaucoup plus que ce qui a été fait
jusqu'à maintenant est ce qui est prévu
de faire je trouve déjà qu'on a des
plans de relance qui ont été inférieures
bien inférieur à ce qui aurait pu être
demandée est attendu dans un contexte de
crise comme le nôtre je rappelle que le
plan de relance européen fait les 390
milliards d'euros de subventions et 360
milliards d'euros de prêts mais qui ne
seront pas utilisés
alors que le parlement européen demande
est 2 milliards d'euros et que thierry
breton le commissaire européen à
l'économie demande est lui aussi 2
milliards
d'euros donc on est très loin des
montants da sur le plan de relance
français en fait il y à 40 milliards
d'euros que la france va toucher de la
part de l'union européenne mais que
finalement on remboursera aussi qui vont
venir s'imputer en moins sur les 100
milliards d'euros et non pas en plus
donc là on a une comparaison avec
l'allemagne qui a enjoint à fait un plan
de relance de 130 milliards d'euros dont
déjà si on le questionnait les 40
milliards d'euros qu'on va recevoir de
l'union européenne aux 100 milliards
d'euros plutôt que de les soustraire on
en référençant plus important juste un
constat rapide en fait la récession pour
l'instant dans dernier projet de loi de
finances on prévoit une récession de 11
points de pib pour l'année 2020 ça
représente une chute du pib d'environ
270 à 280 milliards d'euros et on a un
plan de relance de 100 milliards d'euros
c'est donc tout à fait insuffisant pour
relancer l'activité et bien sûr n'en
parlons pas pour opérer une véritable
politique alors dominique méda parle de
reconversion écologique nous à
l'institut rousseau on parle de
politique de reconstruction et que
logique mais au delà des termes c'est
tout à fait insuffisant pour impulser ce
dynamique là par exemple la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments on sait qu'il
faut 20 milliards d'euros par an pour
rénover 700 mille logements et dans le
plan de relance hull 2 milliards d'euros
seront prévues à travers le dispositif
ma prime rénove de ce que l'on sait
aujourd'hui
donc voilà donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui
il aurait s'agit peut-être remettre en
cause certains dogues ont notamment des
dogues monétaire des dogmes sur la dette
avoir une ambition plus importante
effectivement montré des fonds
d'investissement pour aider les
entreprises et avoir une réponse globale
beaucoup plus ambitieuse que
que celle qui est qu'ils se découragent
aujourd'hui en europe et en france
justement sur ce plan de relance de 100
milliards vous avez l'air tous deux en
tout cas ça tombe d'entre vous de
trouver ça insuffisant est ce que ça
n'est pas tout simplement qu'on peut pas
s'offrir plus
après tout comme la digression
saint-etienne va on est moins riche que
l'allemagne
on est même carrément plus pauvres
maintenant il est logique
donc on est moins 2 milliards à mettre
sur la table normal daniel remarque pas
ses plans de relance moi je trouve pas
qu'il est insuffisant je trouve qu'il
est excessif
au contraire je dois d'abord je citerai
alors c'est un peu prétentieux mais
montagne qui disait que les sujets d'un
prince est excessif ans dont se rendent
excessif en demande
cette idée que on va pouvoir dépenser
les milliards 100 milliards 200 millions
à 300 milliards je pense que ça effraie
la population on lui a dit il ya un
homme qu'on pouvait pas se permettre de
laisser le régime de retraite avoir 12 à
13 milliards de déficit et maintenant on
lui dit on peut dépenser 100 milliards
et des gens lui disent mais pourquoi
s'arrêter à 100 milliards pourquoi pas
120 pourquoi pas s'en prendre et je
crois que c'est non seulement aberrant
aux yeux de la population même anxiogène
et donc on commence à voir effectivement
vous le dites la population ne dépense
pas le cours de l'or monte
il ya toute une partie de la population
mondiale qui commence à s'inquiéter de
cette masse d'argent dont on ne sait pas
d'où il vient et qui est annoncé comme
pouvant être dépensés comme ça sans
aucune conséquence
le deuxième élément c'est que je pense
encore une fois que dans l'immédiat ce
qui s'est passé c'est qu'on n'a pas
travaillé et donc l'enjeu c'est de se
remettre au travail il faut produire et
donc non je ne sais pas de dépenser mais
de permettre aux entreprises de
travailler et je crois que des anges
clair ça devrait être de dire une bonne
fois pour toutes les conditions dans
lequelles va pouvoir travailler
c'était ce qu'il faut un masque pas
masquer ce que comment est ce qu'on va
pouvoir s'organiser et je crois que ça
ça doit être négocié aussi au niveau
local que les entreprises se saisisse de
cette affaire et c'est pas ça ne relève
pas d'un plan de relance et la troisième
remarque que je ferai c'est que
concrètement le capital n'a pas été
détruit et le pouvoir d'achat
potentiellement existe vous le dise
il ya de l'argent et donc je crois que
le véritable enjeu c'est de rétablir
véritablement une forme de confiance dès
que le déconfinement a eu ses remontées
très très vite âge rappelle que en avril
60% de l'appareil de production a été
utilisé et en juillet on était remonté
75% de l'appareil de production alors
que en temps normal on est à 80 2% à
parler de production donc il ya une
capacité tout de suite de réponse et
mais cette réponse et suppose que
effectivement il ya une lecture et une
donne est claire de ce que la politique
que l'on mène et l'idée effectivement
que ça repose sur les entreprises et pas
sur cette espèce de valse des milliards
dont on sait pas d'où ils viennent dont
on sait pas ce qu'on va en faire et qui
sont référencés la conversion écologique
que la solidarité la souveraineté tout
ça est extrêmement confus et je pense
que c'est plus négatif que véritablement
porteur d'avenir
dominique méda n'a pas l'air d'accord
trop d'argent on passait largeur
dominique alors sur les sur les 100
milliards du plan de relance on connaît
pas le contenu mais apparemment il y
aurait 30 milliards justement qui
concernerait l'écologie si j'ai bien
compris 30 milliards sur trois ans et
donc jean marc daniel ai dit qu'on n'a
pas assez travaillé mais moi ce que je
trouve absolument admirable c'est qu'on
dispose aujourd'hui de beaucoup de
travaux je pense à ceux de aïe aïe force
i de la convention climat de wwf etc qui
montrait je ne chante pas vous couper
mais quand je dis qu'on travaille pas
assez c'est pas les intellectuels qu'il
faille passer c'est les jeunes dans les
états fait comme je le dis il vaut mieux
quand il faut commencer par revenir dans
les usines avant d'aller dans les
magasins il faut il faut produire
d'abord été ensuite confirmée chemise
rayée par le beaucoup plus que les
chemises blanches à mon propos
donc vous avez réussi à me déconcentrer
en fait dire qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
travaux qui ont été faits sur la
convention qui nous disent qu'ils nous
disent quoi qu'ils nous disent qu on a
là une occasion historique de faire
cette reconstruction de reconversion
écologique on doit absolument faire pour
éviter ce qui s'est passé en 2008 1
souvenez vous après la crise de 2008
on a fait une relance brune c'est à dire
en utilisant l'énergie fossile et c'est
ce qui nous a éloignés de l'atteinte de
nos objectifs climatiques et en plus on
a eu toute une série d'économies ce qui
traîne
nous on dit un peu comme le gouverneur
de la banque de france aujourd'hui qui
nous en dit attention il faut pas non
plus trop s'endetter
il faut vite revenir redevenir sérieux
et faire finalement de l'austérité
budgétaire
donc moi il me semble que bien sûr qu'il
faut qu'on s'en rejettent massivement
c'est un peu ce compact dans le dans le
bouquin autre voie est possible avec
eric heyer et pascal ok mais s'endetter
pas pour faire n'importe quoi mais pour
mettre tout ce qu'on peut dans cette
reconstruction de notre économie il faut
rebâtir notre économie pour la faire
passer dans une autre situation
rénover les bâtiments investir dans les
infrastructures
on s'est vraiment là on sait à peu près
bien tout ce qu'il faut faire sa demande
à l'argent monstrueux que je reviens ce
que je disais au début
emmanuel macron disait un moment qui
avait pas d'argent magique maintenant
via de l'argent mais sachons l'utiliser
intelligemment mettons tout on a on a
une occasion historique de changer les
choses se remettent sur la bonne route
pour pour les enjeux climatiques et puis
essayons également de conditionner tout
tout cet argent pour la relance toutes
ces aides de les conditionner à des
critères sociaux et environnementaux
mais ça veut dire de munich qu'il
fallait pas dépenser fallait pas donner
18 milliards l aérien et l automobile
qui sont deux secteurs où la france a
des champions et qui surtout il ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'emplois fallait pas
leur donner d'argent
oui mais vous avez vu il ya eu beaucoup
de débats autour de ça c'est à dire que
c'est vraiment dommage qu'il n'y a pas
eu de conditions à la fois sociale et
écologique pour pour cet argent
salut des conditions contraires question
d'un ton meilleur sur qui peuvent
s'effectuer par les tgv ça c'est dit on
aurait pu quand même aller beaucoup plus
loin et puisqu'on parle d'emploi je
rappelle les chiffres qui sont issus la
du rapport wwf et oignons qui est sorti
en juillet qui nous dit qu'on pourrait
soutenir maintenir créer un à deux
millions d'emplois avec la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments l'investissement
dans les infrastructures le train le
ferroviaire et l'agriculture biologique
donc ça c'est quand même quelque chose
d'absolument essentiel qu'on puisse à la
fois complet c'est que c'est le double
dividende à qu'on puisse couple et nos
objectifs climatiques avec une décrue de
la création d'emplois c'est vraiment
formidable
christian saint-etienne d'abord je
voudrais quand même appuyer ce que a dit
dominique méda ça fait longtemps que moi
même je me bats pour la le fait d'isoler
les logements nous avons 30 millions de
résidences principales en france nous
savons qu'il ya huit millions de ce
qu'on appelle épaves thermiques donc il
ya déjà des analyses qui ont été faites
y ont créé une filière qui permettrait
d'isoler par exemple un million de
logements par an il faut créer trois à
quatre cent mille emplois pérennes
donc c'est des emplois qui ne sont pas
délocalisables
mais justement c'est quelque chose qu'on
aurait déjà dû faire depuis 15 ans alors
oui il faut bien voir ce que ça implique
c'est pas seulement de dépenser de
l'argent on sait construire une filière
dont pour construire une filière il faut
des 2 des écoles il faut des actes d de
l'apprentissage
il faut la formation et de l'art
formation donc il faut parce que isolé
des maisons ou des appartements ça se
décrète pas c'est un travail extrêmement
technique il faut former les gens donc
si on crée une vraie filière c'est très
important pourquoi parce que
ça réduit massivement évidemment les
émissions de co2 ça réduit aussi les
importations de pétrole
ça crée donc des emplois pérennes
or il se trouve que dans ce domaine là
nous avons des entreprises extrêmement
puissante parce que c'est les
entreprises qui vont faire l'isolation
nous avons des maisons comme saint
gobain tous les grands constructeurs
donc il faut mettre en place une
politique nationale
il ya déjà eu des réflexions c'est pas
c'est pas un logement par logement qu'on
va rénover il faut rénover des quartiers
entiers voir des villes entières pour
que ce soit efficace
c'est marrant parce qu'on a je ça fait
15 ans qu'on aurait pu commencer ça je
ne comprends pas moi-même
on n'a pas commencé ça et c'est vraiment
maintenant qu'il faut le faire donc on
va dans ça c'est une transition la
transition écologique est très
importante
un autre point sur la transition
écologique et dominique neda parler
d'infrastructures
nous avons des infrastructures qui
doivent être rénovés indépendamment du
fait d'en reconstruire de nouvelles
notamment nos routes peuvent être
numérisés pour augmenter les
possibilités trafic sans avoir à
construire de nouveaux équipements
donc il ya une rénovation complète de
notre système d'infrastructure il faut
rénover notamment tous les transports
publics parce que ce qu'on appelle la
transition écologique c'est une densité
sur des sur des infrastructures de
transport public donc il faut repenser
les villes dans ce dans ce contexte est
donc tout ce travail on le sait qu'il
faut le faire depuis 15 ans donc il faut
vraiment le faire c'est la transition
écologique c'est pas c'est pas l'arrêt
de la production c'est un autre modèle
qui nous permet d'entrer dans la
croissance durable ça ça réduit comme je
le disais les les émissions de co2 mais
c'est très important aussi les
importations d'oeufs
de pétrole et de tout toutes les
matières carbonées
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
cochent beaucoup de cases dans dans les
bonnes politiques qu'il faut mettre en
oeuvre mais l'autre pression j'en doute
c'est une convergence et l'autre
transition qui est absolument majeur
c'est la transition numérique où la
france a pris un retard considérable et
là aussi il faut investir dans la
robotisation et la numérisation de notre
système économique pour reprendre des
parts de marché pour reconstruire un
système productif efficace je donne
juste un chiffre malheureusement vous
prenez les pme les oatei française vous
n'avez encore 35 % quand même pas de
site internet crédible alors que le
chiffre comparable en allemagne et 15%
donc là il ya des initiatives alors la
bpi a déjà pris des initiatives
mais il faut aller beaucoup plus loin et
je termine par là aussi une proposition
on va avoir une année scolaire enfin les
diplômés de 2019 et peut-être même ceux
de 2020 vont avoir du mal à trouver du
boulot mais moi je proposerai une
initiative temporaire qui pourrait durer
deux ou trois ans où les l'état en lien
avec les régions et les départements
proposent un emploi d'un an aux jeunes
diplômés pour les mettre dans les
entreprises pour aider les entrepreneurs
à numériser leur boîte
les jeunes recevant une formation de
deux trois mois puis ensuite on les
envoie dans les entreprises les jeunes
sont très très bon dans toutes les
questions du mérite et ça leur mettrait
le pied à l'étrier
donc il ya une initiative absolument
majeur qui permettrait là aussi de
traiter l'énorme problème d'emploi des
jeunes qu'on va se prendre en plein dans
la figure sur les deux années qui
viennent et qui permettrait d'agir sur
la robotique sur la robotisation
numérisation de notre système productif
qu'est ce que ça peut être rejetée
terrible d'ailleurs cette période de
confinement où la france a été obligée
de constater que non seulement pendant
ces deux mois on n'a pratiquement jamais
utilisé aucune application française
toujours des applications américaines ou
chinoises
peut-être quelques jeux vidéo français à
la limite c'est tout ce qu'on a pu
utiliser
on a un retard considérable et à ma
connaissance l'application stop qu'ovide
ne marche pas de faire une application
de traçage qui fonctionnait la véraison
alors que nous avons des sociétés
d'informatique qui sont très bonnes de
services informatiques parmi les
meilleurs du monde là de mon point de
vue c'est un déficiences de l'état
stratège qui n'a pas compris depuis 15
ans à la fois la transition écologique
dont on parlait tout à l'heure
enfin je reste stupéfait qu'on est pas
relancer cette transition écologique
notamment ses se calme pas compliqué de
construire une filière pour pour traiter
ce problème et la transition numérique
c'est la même chose donc il ya une
déficience d'action publique collective
qui prennent en compte les contraintes
ce que vous venez de rappeler frédéric
est assez terrifiant parce que on a des
gens très très bon dans ces domaines et
il n'y a pas eu d'actions collectives
qui permettent de remonter le niveau de
la france dans les technologies
numériques dit que la wii alors moi je
partage beaucoup de choses qui viennent
d'être dit alors sur le par exemple les
infrastructures notamment des
infrastructures ferroviaires on sait
qu'aujourd'hui faut relancer massivement
le fret ferroviaire on est à moins de
40% en a perdu 40% de fret ferroviaire
au cours des dernières années là où
l'allemagne l'italie mène se sont
maintenus
il faut effectivement rénové 700 mille
logements par an pour atteindre les
objectifs de la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie et on n'y est
pas du tout et il a encore totalement
d'accord on aurait pu construire une
filière on pourrait toujours faire de
l'information aider les entreprises
faire
la réglementation qui va avec aussi la
convention citoyenne pour le climat a
proposé de nombreuses choses
donc effectivement et puis alors sur le
numérique on est entièrement d'accord
sur le numérique faut savoir que même
des services de l'état comme la dgsi la
direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure font appel à des sociétés
américaines pour analyser les données de
sécurité de ressortissants français
pareil sur les quatre sous-marins qui
permettent le très haut débit on est
très dépendant de compagnies étrangères
et notamment de google qui saignait à
construire ses propres câble on a comme
ça toute une série de dépendance qui
nous fragilise et qui ne constitue pas
en effet une preuve de maturité dans la
stratégie de souveraineté industrielle
et développement industriel après je
voudrais aussi revenir sur sur ce qui a
été dit par jean marc daniel tout à
l'heure sur la masse d'argent qui
circule parce que c'est vrai qu'on peut
avoir comme ça une impression de
sidération devant des grands chiffres du
quantitative easing d'aider des plans de
relance mais il faut savoir que ces
plans de relance je lai un peu dit tout
à l'heure
en fait c'est pas grand chose le plan de
relance européen vue qui s'étale sur
trois ans et moins de 0 5% du pib chaque
année donc on n'est vraiment pas sûr un
effort budgétaire très important
et puis surtout il faudrait comprendre
que la monnaie on a un système qui est
un peu schizophrène parce qu'en fait on
a écrit un livre à et grange alain
grandjean donc qui est membre aussi du
haut conseil pour le climat sur la
monnaie écologique est en fait il faut
savoir que la monnaie et la dette sont
liés intimement liés il n'y a pas de
monnaie sans dette il n'y a pas
de dette sans monnaie alors quand on
s'offusque que finalement de ces plans
de relance ou du quantitative easing de
la banque centrale la véritable question
à mon avis qu'on devrait se poser c'est
quelle est la nature de notre système
monétaire qui nous fait dépendre toutes
nos activités de la dette privée comme
publique et comment cette monnaie est
injectée est transmise dans le circuit
économique est là on s'apercevrait que
la banque centrale depuis que les
traités européens ont forcé à ne pas
financer les états à en passer que par
les banques privées tous les canaux de
transmission de la politique monétaire
passe désormais par les banques privées
et donc c'est pour ça qu'on voit des
montagnes de liquidités qui s'accumulent
qui font des bulles sur les marchés
financiers au lieu de venir irriguer
l'économie réelle
christian saint-etienne évoqué la
tout à fait d'accord où il faudrait
aujourd'hui par exemple la bpi il
faudrait tripler au moins son capital la
bpi française à un cas pied à un bilan
total de 75 milliards d'euros
l'afd allemande qui est son équivalent à
un bilan de 500 milliards d'euros
d'envoyer on a on a de la marge et en
plus de ça on a des règles d'engagement
de la bpi qui sont un peu contre
productive puisque on dit que la bpi ne
peut investir quand co investissement ou
un cofinancement avec le privé c'est à
dire que là où le privé n'investit pas
la bpi n'y va pas alors c'est pas comme
ça qu'on je vous attends des déchets
industriels
oui je vous interromps nicolas ont fait
une pause j'en reviens on recomptait en
reprend ce débat pardonnez moi juste
après
[Musique]
c'était une figure nationale il était
connu à l'époque quels étaient les
grands aspects de sa personnalité
gouda de la sablière donc sera un des
plus grands généraux donc de division de
la con d'armé et ce général il sera
toujours fidèle
fidèle à la révolution aussi fidèle à
languir
et s'il n'est pas populaire il est
respecté ça sans aucun problème et
lorsque il va être atteint par ce boulet
de canon le 19 août 1912 ça va être une
grande perte aujourd'hui français et
russes main dans la main pour retrouver
les ossements du général gul un comment
diplomatiquement cette découverte
résonne tel par mois je pense qu'elle
arrive au au meilleur moment
parce que je pense que les liens entre
la russie et la france médias
historiques
entre 800 et 1000 tonnes de fuel se sont
déversés dans les eaux turquoises
mauricienne ce qu'il faudrait étendre
l'enquète aux autorités portuaires voir
plus haut
une fois nous devons maintenant établir
la chaîne de responsabilités nationales
il faut savoir que la partie arrière du
bateau contient encore environ 50 à 100
tonnes de fuel donc ça pourrait aussi
actuellement se fracasser et causé un
deuxième déversement de pétrole plus ça
arrive après les collègues 19
nous avons secteur hôtelier et
touristique est à genoux en semant des
impacts de la catastrophe sur
l'environnement marin mais aussi sur les
populations niveau de la santé devront
se faire ressentir pendant des décennies
il faut s'attendre aujourd'hui à maurice
aussi un désastre sanitaire
il est catastrophe on aura vécu voilà
pourquoi je suis pas si pessimiste que
c'est
[Musique]
comment sortir de la crise que nous
avons provoqué en mettant ses l'économie
sur pause pendant les deux mois de
confinement
on en débat avec jean marc daniel qui
est économiste c'est l'auteur de macron
la vache folle de jupiters éditions de
l'archipel avec dominique méda une j'ai
dit la valse folle dominique méda
qu'auteur d'une autre voie est possible
qui ressort en poche chez flammarion
dans une édition augmentée christian
saint-etienne qui vient de publier le
libéralisme stratège contre le chaos du
monde chez odile jacob et nicolas
dufresne quelques auteurs avec un à
grandjean du livre une monnaie ecologic
qui était paru en février dernier chez
odile jacob
un mot puisque on a parlé d' état
stratège
ce haut commissariat au plan le
commissariat au plan a connu ses heures
de gloire sous la quatrième république
sont sous georges pompidou sous
évidemment général de gaulle il y avait
un formidable plan calcul qu'on a arrêté
à l'époque qui nous aurait peut-être
permis d'indépendance informatique que
nous n'avons pas toujours est il que ça
revient et que c'est françois bayrou qui
va être le haut commissaire au plan
penser que ça peut être une norme moyen
de nous sortir de là j'ai qualifié cette
idée dans un journal de loufoque et en
quoi j'étais modéré dans ma façon
d'appréhender la situation
je suis assez surpris du tour de la
conversation parce que que l'état ait
besoin d'être stratège bon encore une
fois on n'est pas en 1944 même si je
pense qu'il faut donc produire mais
quand jean monnet a créé le commissariat
général au plan d'abord il avait eu la
sagesse de dire qu' il était installé
dans le bureau de jules méline et il
avait eu la sagesse de renvoyer le
portrait de jules méline symbole du
protectionnisme français à la casse donc
il considérait que une des premières
choses que devait faire l'économie
française c'est est de s'ouvrir alors
qu'on est plutôt dans une période où
nous annonce qu'il faut être souverain
qu'il faut se méfier des importations il
faut reconstituer des chaînes de
production française donc je pense qu'on
est à rebours même de la pensée de jean
monnet et la deuxième chose que les
fêtes jean monnet c'est de recruter un
cuisinier parce qu'il considérait que le
plus utile dans le plan c'était de
mettre autour de la même table les
partenaires sociaux je pense que si mes
roues en reste là c'était s'il garde
l'idée qu'il faut que melide reste à la
cave et qu'il est un bon cuisinier ce
sera à peu près acceptable mais cette
idée que il faut d'état stratège qui
pourquoi pas mais je crois que
l'immédiateté n'est pas dans l'état
stratège il ya tout un tas de chefs
d'entreprise qui se pose la question de
savoir s'ils seront encore là à la fin
de l'année leur considération c'est pas
de savoir est ce que on a bien fait le
plan numérique est ce que le plan calcul
aurait dû être leur vraie question c'est
qu'on a détruit leurs fonds propres les
empêchant de travailler pendant 55 jours
et est ce que les prêts garantis par
l'état vont être maintenues est-ce que
lorsqu'ils vont faire revenir des champs
dans leurs usines dans leur lieu de
travail
est-ce qu'ils sont être menacés de
procès si les masques ne sont pas porter
correctement
est-ce que
un certain nombre de décisions qui ont
été annoncées vont être maintenus on va
être rapportées donc je crois que on a
besoin - de considérations générales
telles que françois bayroux peuvent les
pour et les incarner et plus d'éléments
concrets axé sur cette idée que pour
qu'ils aient des employés il faut qu'ils
aient des employeurs et donc la première
nécessité c'est de sauvegarder notre
tissu productif actuelle
la deuxième remarque que je ferai c'est
pour en revenir à l'idée que l'on
dépense pas tant que cela je maintiens
quand même que tous ces plans de relance
toute cette annonce de du déversement ne
sommes colossales est en train de
provoquer des mécanismes anxiogène
deux éléments pour ça je maintiens que
quand vous avez un prix de l'or ktm 2000
dollars l'once alors qu'il ya 50 ans il
était à 35 dollars l'once
vous avez une sorte de sanction par la
vie quotidienne du marché d'une sorte de
dérive sur le rapport à la monnaie qui
est une dérive qui encore une fois
enquête la population et vous avez un
autre élément dans ça c'est que vous
avez de plus de plus de plus en plus de
gens qui sont qui gardent des billets
alors que rld annonce qu'on va créer de
la monnaie qui à y perdre les banques
sont en train de demander à la
population de rapporter les billets
c'est à dire la quantité de billets en
circulation qui représentait avant la
crise environ 7 à 8% de la production
maintenant est porté à environ 10 à 12%
de la production alors la production a
reculé mais vous avez une augmentation
de la thésaurisation de billets et les
banques manquent de billets parce que la
population se dit entre le compte en
banque que toute cette monnaie et le
billet finalement le billet plus sûr
donc je crois le billet son matelas le
midi sous le matelas dans quel est ce
mécanisme d'autorisation alors on dîne
ont baissé de l'épargné forcée
non non c c'est de la vraie théorisation
de la vraie angoisse parce que l'épargné
c'est un élément assez positif l'épargné
c'est ce qui va être porté vers
l'investissement c'est ce qui va servir
non là c'est vraiment la thésaurisation
balzacienne c'est le et ça c'est issus
de toutes ces politiques dont je
maintiens qu'elles sont par nature
anxiogène
on parle l'équivalence ricardienne
canton sa façon un peu sa vente je pense
que tous ces mécanismes sont en train de
se mettre en place et la première
sagesse qu'on devrait avoir
c'est de remettre de l'ordre dans les
finances publiques le haut commissariat
au plan
vous en espérer quelque chose dominique
méda mais moi je trouve que c'est une
super idée
j'ai vécu le passage du commissariat au
plan a ça s'appelait le centre d'analysé
stratégique une grosse énergie
elle domine sens voilà j'avais participé
un rapport super intéressant avec un
merveilleux groupe de travail sous la
direction de jean boissonnat on avait
écrit le travail dans 20 ans en 1995 et
ce rapport proposait notamment une idée
qui n'a bien sûr pas été mises en oeuvre
j'avais le contrat d'activité et qui
consistait à mettre en place en quelques
sortes les organisations permettant
d'éviter aux personnes de passer par la
case chômage
c'était vraiment très très très très
très intéressant et j'ai encore un
désaccord avec jean marc daniel à redon
n'est donc je pense que la tâche de
planification de coordination de
conception de reconstruction elle est
absolument majeur elle ne doit pas
seulement incomber à l'état mais aussi
bien sûr aux collectivités territoriales
avec les entreprises et les ménages à
l'évidence mais je crois qu'il faut un
chef d'orchestre
on en a eu besoin moment de la
reconstruction pour nos marques volume
en besoin maintenant parce que je
reviens sur ce que disait christian
saint-etienne tout à l'heure sur l'ecc
sur les emplois une autre chose que nous
n'avons pas su faire
c'est anticiper les mutations
c'est pour ça que j'utilise le terme de
reconversion écologique parce que je
pense qu'il faut à la fois une intense
conversion intellectuelle pour faire
cette reconversion écologique mais on va
être aussi face à la nécessité
opérationnel de reconvertir des gens et
des territoires c'est à dire va falloir
fermer des secteurs qui émettent trop de
gaz à effet de serre et en ouvrir
beaucoup d'eau et ça ça se fait qu'on ne
peut pas laisser le hasard faire ça on
doit coordonner et de ces choses là il
notamment
quelque chose qui m'étonne énormément
c'est qu'on n'est pas encore pensé à
cartographier les compétences de toutes
les personnes qui travaillent dans le
secteur qui doit être fermée et les
compétences désirer
nécessaires dans les organisations a à
offrir
on a eu un seul travail un peu général
là dessus il a été fait par laurence
parisot avec une équipe de la dgefp etc
c'est une sorte de programmation de
blanc pour les emplois et les
compétences c'est un rapport tout à fait
intéressant qui nous montre chaque
secteur
combien on va pouvoir fermer ou ouvrir
d'emplois et comment on va faire très
finement les nouveaux appariement
nécessaire mais ça on devrait avoir
mais des centaines de personnes là
dessus donc si le commissariat au plan
le nouveau commissaire io fa doit faire
ça ça je trouve ça vraiment formidable
vous y croyez
clijsters a détiennent moi je pense
qu'il ya deux aspects de ce projet le
premier c'est celui qu'a évoqué jean
marc daniel effectivement les gens se
parlent plus sur le long terme et donc
remettre les partenaires sociaux autour
la table alors c'est pas seulement il
faut faire attention malgré tout parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'archaïsme chez les
partenaires sociaux y compris au medef
qui n'est pas forcément je vais me faire
des amis mais elle est la plus marquante
du patronat donc il faut des gens venant
de croissance plus il faut des gens
justement du du secteur des nouvelles
technologies
mais je crois que c'est très important
on évoquer par exemple tout à l'heure la
construction d'une filière nouvelle
entière de de croissance durable de
commençant par l'isolation des bâtiments
et la rénovation des infrastructures
bon ben ça ça se fait pas comme ça en
claquant les doigts
il faut nous avons de très belles
entreprises dans ce secteur comme je
l'évoquais il faut les mettre autour
d'une table avec les présidents de
région avec les présidents de
départements et les grandes
collectivités locales moi j'avais fait
j'ai déjà fait par un cri dans des
journaux une proposition que je reprend
d'ailleurs dans mon livre sur le
libéralisme stratège
moi je savais que nous
nous sommes tombés de 136000 à 35000
commune mais les trente cinq mille
collines sont toutes reliées à 1200
intercommunalités moi je proposerai de
passer l'élection communale de la
commune à l'intercommunalité et je
créerai sans aucun changement
institutionnel je transformerai
simplement les intercoms en
j'appellerais ça comme une communes
métropolitaines et surtout je donnerais
par la loi obligation à ces communes
métropolitaines c'est à dire des actuels
interco de faire des plans de
programmation stratégique à 6 ans
renouvelé tous les trois ans et je
donnerai au département dans un premier
temps la mission de les intégrer et
ensuite également l'intégration au
niveau des régions et donc l'idée étant
à ce point là que je rejoins jean marc
sur un point c'est pas françois bayroux
qui est tout à fait estimable mais qui
va nous dire quelle entreprise doit
produire quoi ça doit venir du terrain
mais en revanche que cette co
intégration se fasse dans le nouveau
commissariat au plan
notamment grâce à une très belle cuisine
pourquoi pas mais ce qui est très
important c'est qu'on mette autour de la
table les gens qui vont créer et
développer cette filière et l'état c'est
pas celui qui dit on va investir amis
qui ont ici ou là
l'état doit être le facilitateur celui
qui met tout le monde autour de la table
avec un une ambition parce que si on dit
qu'il faut isoler 700 mille huit cent
mille neuf cent mille logements par an
bah il faut avoir une planification qui
disent ou est-ce qu'on commence comment
on fait
qui le fait voilà donc c'est tout ce
travail qu'il faut qu'il faut réaliser
parce que ça ne va pas se faire
naturellement
nicolas mot sur le commissariat au plan
le retour
oui alors déjà on n'est pas dénué
complètement d'organismes stratégique y
pense on affrontera tj on a un
commissariat général à l'investissement
qui distribue les sommes dues du pays à
1 du programme d'investissements
d'avenir
on a bon on à une époque on avait des
plans industriels là c'était arnaud
montebourg qui avait bâti 34 plan
industriel
trente quatre filières qui ont
aujourd'hui on était un peu bon qui ont
été plus ou moins abandonnée par par
emmanuel macron quand il lui a succédé
bon aujourd'hui on a des des organismes
et tout ça est très dispersé c'est vrai
qu'on manque de vision et qu'on manque
un peu de pilotage de tout ça moi je
pense que le la planification est donc
un la planification c'est une idée n'a
finalement a parfois il ya cette
citation de régis debray que j'aime
beaucoup qui dit parfois c'est par le
rétroviseur qu'on avance donc donc
aujourd'hui effectivement moi je le
trouverai pas mal qu'on regarde un petit
peu ce qui s'est fait en effet au moment
de la reconstruction en 1945 pourquoi
parce que à l'époque
qu'est-ce qui nous a sorti des
difficultés héritées de la guerre c'est
le camp marshall qui est un plan et
c'est des plantes successives de
reconstruction en france et en europe et
on avait pour appuyer ses plans un
circuit du trésor qui permettait de
drainer l'épargné des banques vers des
investissements qui étaient décidées
pour le futur c'est comme ça qu'on a eu
un grand plan d'investissement pour
l'énergie pour le ferroviaire pour tout
ce qui est ensuite les atouts de la
france tous les to
voilà donc on avait on avait aussi une
capacité d'emprunter à notre banque
centrale d'avoir des avances à hors des
avances remboursables qui étaient des
prêts à taux zéro ils mènent des
avancements remboursa qui étaient des
subventions de la création monétaire
libre sans dette en contrepartie qui ont
permis de d'investir massivement et ça
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment quelque chose
dans livre avec alain grandjean c'est
notamment ce qu'on recommande en plus de
faire de l'annulation dette
conditionnelle pour la bce
voilà donc on moi je pense qu'on a
beaucoup beaucoup à apprendre et à
reprendre de cette période du plan de la
planification l'état pouvait compter sur
des outils financiers industriels
puissants et voilà alors juste je
termine avec un dernier point parce je
voulais rebondir tout à l'heure on se
posait la question comment sortir les 75
à 100 milliards d'euros départ en force
et qui ont été accumulées ces derniers
temps bas peut-être que pour ça il faut
pas faire qu'une politique de l'offre
mais faire aussi un peu une politique de
la demande dans le plan de relance de ce
qu'on en sait aujourd'hui il n'y a
aucune baisse de tva contrairement à
l'allemagne qui va baisser sa tva qui va
baisser sa tva d'ailleurs et qui l'avait
déjà fait de manière un peu ciblées par
exemple sur les billets de train pour
relancer le transport par le train dans
une optique de transition écologique de
on a on n'a pas non plus de relance
du point d'indicé qui est gelé depuis
dix ans on a pas on n'a pas voilà on a
on a une épargne forcée qu'on ne va pas
aider à se débloquer pourquoi les gens
aujourd'hui ne ne consomme pas c'est pas
parce que c'est pas à cause de
l'équivalence ricardienne c'est pas
parce qu'ils ont peur que demain leurs
impôts augmentent c'est parce que tout
simplement il n'y a pas de perspective
et si on fait qu'une politique de
l'offre et que les autres entreprises
n'ont pas plus de perspective demain
d'avoir des débouchés d'avoir des
marchés tout ça ne servira pas à grand
chose et ça ne comblera pas l'écart avec
les autres pays
la question que se posent aussi pas mal
de français
j'avais peut-être pouvoir y répondre
puisque vous êtes si soucieux des
entreprises jean marc daniel c est ce qu
il va falloir travailler plus alors on a
bien vu la large à l'université du medef
c'était quand même là oui je pense qu'il
va falloir travailler plus c'est ce que
je disais d'ailleurs dans les
propositions que vous m'aviez demandé en
tout début d'émission
je pense qu'il va falloir supprimer les
jours de plongée et donc je pense encore
une fois que la création de richesse
c'est pas de la création de monnaies
c'est pas la banque centrale qui créent
la richesse c'est les gens qui vont dans
des usines pour travailler et je pense
que vous avez un problème en ce moment
dont petit un problème là aussi de moyen
long terme il a été amplifié c'est que
la productivité n'est pas au rendez vous
donc il faut travailler plus parce que
l'efficacité du capital ne se développe
pas comme on l'espérait et parce que
pendant 55 jours on n'a pas travaillé
donc je pense qu'il faut travailler plus
quant à l'idée que
on va manquer de demande encore une fois
les gens ont théorisé si vous baissez la
tva ça va pas les inciter à dépenser
plus
ils ont thésaurisé non pas parce que la
tva est trop importante ils ont
thésaurisé parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
véritable lecture de l'avenir et et
/ alors dominique méda pour travailler
plus dans le rapport de jean boissonnat
je pense qu'elle se souvienne de
l'introduction de jean boissonnat et de
danse jean boissonnat disait que le tram
groupes de travail avaient écarté assez
rapidement l'hypothèse des 35 heures
parce que ça lui avait paru nom actuel
on est en 95 et le groupe de tragédies
les 35 heures ce ne peut pas être actuel
et jean boissonnat avait accordé une
interview à l'expansion qui était son
journal d'origine
ça me paraît tellement absurde de faire
les 35 heures que je pense que c'est
quelque chose qu'on ne peut pas utiliser
donc je pense qu'effectivement on rentre
dans une période où moment où on est en
train d'oublier avec falloir faire la
semaine de quatre jours il ya certains
dorment dans la convention citoyenne
byers avait été évoquée l'idée des 28
heures je pense qu'il va falloir
travailler plus néanmoins pour conclure
sur cet aspect là je pense que la nature
du travail va changer et que le score
n'aura retirer de cette période de
confinement c'est l'émergence du
télétravail
c'est à dire le fait que le travail dans
un lieu près déterminer qui était un peu
le travail industriel une usine c'est
des gens qui sont dans un lieu avec une
chaîne qui sont contraints dans
l'organisation de leur travail et en
plus avec un masque à partir de lundi
prochain album est donc ce travail là
dans l'économie du numérique dans
l'économie de la connaissance dans
l'économie de l'échangé est un travail
qui peut être délocalisés d'une certaine
façon qui peut être organisée autour du
télétravail le président de la
république à l'époque où il était
candidat avait dit on va passer de la
société employeur employé à la société
clients fournisseurs et je pense que là
il ya une vraie réflexion sur ce que va
devenir le travail mais l'idée qu' on va
voir travail salarié pendant quatre
jours et que c'est ça la solution somme
paraît pour revenir à jean boissonnat et
j'insiste auprès de dominique bédard
ça vous paraît notes actuelles sont
alice créateur de l'expansion dominique
méda vous pensez comme jean daniel
méthodes non mais non et alors pour
avoir tenu la plume de ce rapport je
peux vous dire que dans le scénario rose
vous savez on le faisait toujours à
l'époque un scénario noir scénario noir
et n'a donc dans le scénario rose bien
sûr qui était prévu la réduction du
temps de travail et peut-être que jean
boissonnat nous partager parce sénat
dont le départ était prévu était prévu
une forte réduction du temps de travail
et alors vous avez vu aussi que le grand
syndicat allemand ig metall qui est très
sérieux bras car compagnie quand même en
partie par qui a été obligé d'accepter
les réformes ars demandent le passage à
trente deux soeurs et moi si vous voulez
si vous me demandez quel est mon nom ma
solution idéale monde idéal je dirais
que certainement qu'avec la reconversion
écologique on va être on va avoir besoin
de plus de travail humain d'ailleurs
c'était en effet la première phrase du
rapport boissonnat c'était le travail ne
manque pas donc on va avoir besoin de
plus de travail humain parce que on va
devoir économiser ces adjuvants
chimiques et mécaniques qui son émetteur
de gaz à effet de serre mais là où on
devra montrer notre intelligence c'est
dans notre capacité à répartir ce boom
de travail supplémentaires sur
l'ensemble de la population en âge de
travailler et à mon avis en fin de
compte on arrivera certainement à une
certaine forme de réduction du temps de
travail et est en tout cas ce qui me
semble essentiel ce qui me semble
essentiel c'est de ne pas aux procédés
comme on l'a fait jusqu'à maintenant
alors des pays l'ont fait de façon pire
que noah justement allemagne et
royaume-uni ne pas procéder en
promouvant le temps partiel mais en
promouvant une réduction de la norme de
travail à temps complet pour pour tous
est-ce qu'on va arriver est ce qu'on va
parvenir à rembourser tout cet argent
est ce qu'il va falloir le rembourser
parce que la l'endettement est
historique mais pas seulement
les collectivités publiques les
entreprises privées aussi qu'en pensez
vous christian saint-etienne
il ya quelque chose qu'on n'a pas abordé
je vais répondre sursis rosso cet aspect
là on essayé on a on s'attend tous à une
baisse due de la production en 2020 de
l'ordre de 10%
bon il ya des prévisions qui avaient été
faites à -11 d'autres à moins 9
ça va apprendre ont terminé à moins 10
mais c'est pas toutes les entreprises
qui baisse de -10 donc c'est une
mutation qui est en cours c'est à dire
que vous allez l'avoir 30% des
entreprises qui vont faire + 10 %
vous allez avoir 50% des entreprises qui
vont effectivement faire moins 10 mais
vous allez enfin avoir 20% des
entreprises qui vont faire moins 40
parce que soit une partie d'entre eux
vont disparaître soit elles vont être
restructurés et donc le point central
c'est que quand on dit qu'il faut quand
on parle du temps de travail ne peut pas
être le même partout dans les
entreprises des 30% d'entreprises que
j'évoquais qui vont en avoir 10 ou 15 %
d'activité de plus cette année qui ont
déjà une suractivité parce qu'elles
répondent à la demande dans les secteurs
que les français privilégient
aujourd'hui la cie la décision de tandt
avait peut-être fait au niveau local à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise ça fait sens
s'il ya beaucoup de demandes adressées à
cette entreprise de travailler 40 42
heures au 44 eur et d'augmenter l'emploi
et d'augmenter le temps de travail parce
que ce faisant on crée de la richesse
donc on crée des recettes fiscales et
donc on crée aussi en distribuer du
pouvoir d'achat ce qui va irriguer le
reste de l'économie
donc dans ces secteurs là ça peut tout à
fait faire sens de travailler 45 heures
par semaine peut-être pendant six mois
un nom 18 mois le pour répondre à cette
demande si on bloque ses secteurs qui
sont qui font face à une demande forte
c'est un carcan qu'on met sur tout le
monde donc ça c'est le point central
sur effectivement l'autre point qui est
clé qui a été évoqué par la dominique
méda que peu de gens comprennent c'est
que du travail il y en a il y en a
beaucoup
la question c'est que on n'a pas
forcément les gens qualifiés pour
répondre à ce travail mais revenons au
regard dans le rétroviseur comme ça a
été dit tout à l'heure
placez-vous en 1801 en 1800 il ya 20
millions d'habitants en france 24 25
millions et 80 % sont dans l'agriculture
il vous dit aux gens à ce moment là dans
deux siècles droite 3 % des gens dans
l'agriculture et on sera 67 millions et
le nom les gens qui travaillent
or on trie le nombre de gens qui
travaillent aura triplé les gens vous
aurez en fermer immédiatement en disant
d'être complètement cinglé c'est parce
qu'en fait on n'imagine pas les
possibilités de développement comme on
l'a dit allez au début de cette émission
la filière de d'isolation des logements
ces trois à quatre cent mille emplois
pérennes sur les trente à quarante
prochaines années
mais il ya plein d'autres secteurs si on
développe massivement la robotisation et
la numérisation en sorte qu'on produise
en france et à tout le moins en europe
des technologies c'est des millions
d'emplois voilà donc c'est très
important de ne pas avoir une norme
unique sur la durée du travail dans les
entreprises qui sont en difficulté ça
peut-être utile de passer à quatre jours
par semaine
loria 1.1 kg et clé en allemagne quand
on en allemagne hongrie 32 heures s'est
payé 32 heures en france quand on passe
de 39 à 35 cpi 39 en allemagne elle va
devenir une minute sur les allemands
face à bolton
nicolas
dufresne et
sur l'emploi ou sur le remboursement des
dettes est ce qu on les remboursera ses
dettes à jour je pense qu on les
remboursera probablement pas alors après
le bond est par exemple une dette
publique ça se fait rouler dans le temps
sauf que le problème c'est que là le
niveau de l'endettement va être
tellement élevé que à chaque fois que
l'endettement grandi il ya toujours
ensuite des tendance à vouloir le
réduire y compris et c'est problématique
quand on emprunte à taux négatifs on
voit que depuis 2015 on emprunte à taux
nul ou négatif
et pourtant la moyenne des états
européens s'est désendetté au cours des
cinq dernières années avant la crise
alors nous ce qu'on a proposé notamment
avec avec gaël giraud avec d'autres
économistes avec mon co auteur alain
grandjean c'est qu'on puisse aujourd'hui
annuler la partie des dettes publiques
des tirs la banque centrale en échange
d'investissements de même montant dans
la transition écologique dans la
transition sociale dans tout ce dont on
vient de parler
pourquoi parce que ça ne coûterait rien
à personne parce qu'une banque centrale
ne peut pas faire faillite bien
évidemment et parce que ça permettrait
de fournir une incitation à investir qui
serait très importante et c'est là
dessus que on pourrait bâtir des plans
de relance qui en soit vraiment je
rappelle que la banque centrale détient
près de 2300 milliards d'euros au niveau
de l'union européenne si on annulait la
partie qu'elle détient ce qui ne
pénaliserait je le répète aucun
épargnant aucun ménage on pourrait on
aurait de quoi faire des plans de
relance autrement plus important est
opéré tout ces transitions dont on parle
depuis tout à l'heure
merci tous les quatre d'avoir parce que
gps débat merci de nous avoir suivis
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]